here we go on the yellow submarine or
something like that okay let's see what
I can do against the yellow submarine
oops a mouse clip okay yeah hehe asked
for take back I will grind it but he
didn't I'm not asking myself or offer it
myself so what do I go here like h3
maybe net the bishop am some chow it's
not the hit it doesn't look good but
it's not super terrible the position is
very close so a 3 before I guess not
really a shooting for reputation but
with my recent games i am happy to have
something that is some quite quite let's
say simple to play and things that are
quite conventional okay Quincy 6 may be
here let's do that taking looks wrong
and i have 9 p-5 ideas like that might
be five maybe thanks Tex okay everybody
one may be empty one
you
it fits into the position
9 p-5 here maybe
let's do that
J even if he goes Bishop f8 it's not so
clear what I'm accomplishing maybe just
taking on c5 there I also think this
might be an interesting idea for
possible doubling on the B file okay so
it tries to trap my queen better better
go back but isn't it is okay the Queen
sortie didn't hurt me
so what now yeah p5 he goes back if he
takes it takes for the night so I
probably just covered c4 keep things
protected
h5 bishop age six might be an idea for
him just going back
catch ya it's not so easy to to make any
headway as nice as it looks I have an
idea though maybe queen bee three and
then at the right moment like b5 a4 a5
it's very close though I probably maybe
I should try to get some Bishop h3 in
like a g3 Bishop f1 this kind of thing
it's very slow though not sure if it's a
good idea ok this is maybe a good moment
to do it as he has to go to be aid b6 is
hanging a 505 so really holding this
this stuff that's quite quite honey oh
so I get that that should be really nice
actually let's see how to do it look
here and ok go let's go here just keep
that completely controlled now see how
to continue I have to maybe get the
bishop involved I wonder if Bishop g4 is
a move just to activate this
ah let's do this prevent night h5 and
then maybe Bishop d3 making my pieces
more flexible
53 so now I can move my knight so I can
go here and then I'd be five on the next
smooth yeah otherwise mighty four point
would have would have hung so that that
was the point Jim so ya Farooq's is
Sapna it's quite funny a full-scale
invasion nights night the night scare
the Knights cannot move
but how how to win me hey here like g4
f3h 45 this kind of thing yeah bishop
and there i have night d 6 I think yeah
I have 96
96 queen of eight maybe hmm ok but I can
I can move the rookie I am that that's
probably easier easier is wrong maybe
better maybe just better still d6 is
hanging and I'm threatening g5 that
should should be good ok
so g5 now time warning I really hope I'm
not screwing this one up that would be a
total how Allah night age five he still
still has this night f for business okay
okay let's let's do the pin down but he
cannot play Knight h5 yeah okay now I'm
know I'm really winning the house black
resigned Elsa was strange them yeah king
of a truly should have tried to refute
it a little bit harder this early King
evade I just played normal moves and
somehow he got a fairly decent position
out of it but a decent I mean widest is
better but after king of aid you feel
like it should should fall apart and
clay I didn't it was just a
strangulation kind of kind of approach
yeah I think this is this is quite okay
I always I can win the Queen I can win
the Queen yet yeah this is this and here
traps the Queen that's nice okay that
was that was was doable but ok I mean I
was I just had a plan a long-term plan
and it was okay in 96 ok computer says
I'm winning but I wasn't sure ok this is
a move i did not see and its strong for
night f5
so but it's it's it's still like plus a
million yeah this is I don't know this
makes things a bit trickier with night
f-fine maybe has some kind of play so
this and now I mean is just totally tied
down on all groans plus eight so comp
evaluation yeah it just falls apart yeah
I was quite nice this um this dominating
position here with the rooks against the
Queen okay thanks for watching